so hey everybody i'm maxim i'm a
developer advocate
based in paris and i work for mongodb
uh so i want to show you how i built uh
back in january
last year so at the very beginning of
kovid
a graphql and rest api uh
using john upkin's university data set
um so everybody knows that in
2019 right the world was a very good
place to live in right
and then you know 2021 uh happened
so well 2020 and 2021 so yeah
we all know where we are now so uh
at the very beginning of that pandemic
my goal was to
make the data available to everybody
right so
make a cool chart like those for example
and of course make all the data
available through apis so everybody
could benefit from those
run analytics maybe even help
governments you know try to take
decisions these kind of things right
and i started this project back in
january so when it was really the
beginning of the pandemia actually
back in china so that was my goal right
so i needed something uh
quick and easy and i needed a data
source uh so
of course i was inspired by john upkins
university
i think we have all seen this cool
dashboard that they provided us
also at the very beginning of the
pandemi and luckily for me they provided
soon enough a github repository which
you can see here with a small arrow
and it looks like this right so you have
a github repository and it contains
a lot of csv files right so
as you can see there are a few folders
especially the data one
and uh to produce all those data sets so
all the data
basically they aggregated many data
sources from many
uh different sources right so from
different countries different
governments different
entities uh et cetera et cetera so just
to give you an id
that's how many sources are used right
so
definitely i didn't wanted to do my own
parsing and my own
data gathering so they did a really good
job here so
i had no intention at all to try to beat
the the data set they did so i reused
uh humbly what they done and i tried to
produce my own thing but based on that
right so
the data is as good as uh what they
provided
um the word with right basically
so in those folders it produces uh daily
reports like uh like those right so it
looks
looks nice right you have one csv file
for each day so it looked like a very
good idea you know to just
use them and just you know populate the
api and the data
the data set with those files if you
look a bit closely
uh like if we zoom in one of those files
for example the very first one that was
published actually
uh which was a january 22nd
of 2020 uh you see you have that file
right so it looks nice you have
province slash date country slash
region some dates and some some
some values of course of confirmed
deaths and recovered cases
you see some data is missing but it's
probably zeros you see
the die the date has a certain format
etc etc
uh soon enough uh if you check another
file
you see it's actually completely
different so you have like
uh like new columns uh you have
uh it's not proven slash state anymore
it's province underscore state so that's
annoying because it would
make a different field uh in mongodb
um then you have a different format for
the date you have latitude and longitude
now and with
longitude with a weird underscore at the
end of the column name
uh you have zeros now so the data is not
missing anymore it's actually zeros
uh so it's a mess right it's a big
big mess so not consistent not very
predictable
looks like the format of the files can
change basically daily
i i can't really rely on that that's
really really not good
so when you're planning on designing and
working on an api like this
basically you want to reduce as much as
possible the number of wtf per minute
right
so you need to make sure that it's
consistent it's
always the same thing it's predictable
so your users
know what they can expect from your api
so i was looking for another solution
and there is another folder
next to this one which is a time series
folder and in this one it's much more
simpler much more smaller
in a way you have only five files five
csv files
built as a time series so as you can see
you have like three files for what they
call the global
the global file so that's where you have
all the countries
eventually divided in sub sub sub
subregions
sub states for some of them or province
and then you have the u.s where they
don't gather recovered
cases but you have two big files for
just the us because they are subdivided
into states and
counties so it's a lot more subdivided
so based on this if you look at if we
look at one of those files
of course it's divided by a type of
cases so this is global
confirm for example so you have only
confirmed cases for example in this file
but i have something much more clean
right i have a proven state
country latitude and longitude for each
pinpoint so that would be very helpful
to build some kind of maps and
and yeah and charts like this and as you
can see i have one colon
uh for each day right so each day they
basically
do a new commit in that repository and
add an extra colon
all the way to the right you know to add
that new extra day
so it looks good enough looks very good
but
if i import this directly in mongodbu i
can use
[ __ ] import tool for example which
handles csv files quite nicely
i would end up with this kind of schema
design right which is a terrible ski by
design you can't really work with this
right
so it's pretty terrible to have the date
like this as a field
and not as an actual value
so and also like i would like to have
something like that instead right
a date and with an actual is a date
right not just some kind of string
that would be much more helpful also if
you look at the
latitude and longitude it would be much
easier to have a geo
json document like this it's much easier
and supported and mongodb to work like
this
so i needed to transform this and make
it much
better and nicer right what i wanted in
the first place
was to have really one document uh with
one date
one place and the numbers for this
particular day so let's say
france uh i want a confirmed death
recovered cases
for the 22nd of january 2020 for example
that's what i wanted so with all that
there is also one table that is actually
useful it's a lookup table they provided
so all those documents and lines can be
associated with one of those lines here
so i can recover
some extra stuff like the uid iso codes
for the countries population etc etc
and with all that and some python magic
i came up with this right so i just uh
parsed all those documents all the csv
data and produced something that looked
like this which is much
more easy to work with and much more
convenient so the schema design i can't
repeat this enough it's very important
in mongodb and in databases in general
so and here you can see that i have
information about the place
so here it's uh france right and i have
some
one date and i have some numbers right
so exactly what i wanted and with this i
can
really do easily some charts and stuff
like that the one i presented actually
at the very beginning of that
presentation so i came up
in the end with a few different database
collections
so as you can see i produce like some
summary for each countries
uh produce the global collection which
is based on the global files only
the us only which is based on the two
files from the us
and then i regrouped global and us only
into global and us which uh
uh allowed me to do a much more precise
map right with all the pin the small
points for the us
in the global collection the us is just
one big country so one big point for
each day
which is not very precise if you want to
do a map
so with this i can know um
i have no data in mongodb it's actually
available
for free if you i will share at the end
the links but you can actually access
this
this database for free and play with it
and build some cool products
and with this i wanted to build then a
rest api and a graphql api on top of
this
so let's uh let's do that let's hack
so let's see
so first i go to mongodb atlas right
that's where
my project lives right so i have here in
my project
three clusters i have a pre-prod cluster
and the actual production cluster the
one that is actually available
to everybody and
the data is in here right so i actually
connected here with mongodb compass so
you can see basically the
same the same thing and refresh and you
see those collections and
those those documents so for example if
i look in the global collection
that's the type of documents i just
presented in my in my slide deck
right so
um let's see so first thing build the
rest api so for that i go to realm which
is a serverless
platform that's built on top of mongodb
atlas and i can build a rest api
in here so the first thing i'm going to
do here is create a new application
right so
this is a production one the one people
are actually using right now in
production
they sent 215
requests already in the last hour so you
see it's pretty pretty
popular i would say it's working so
let's create a new api
uh a new a new application sorry and i'm
going to call it like api days
18k for example i'm going to use
the production cluster and i'm going to
deploy this
in ireland because the cluster is living
in ireland right now
so i'm going to deploy that app it takes
a few seconds
like this and uh now i can build
all my backend system basically in here
so uh for example
uh here i can manage the rules the
schemas i will have to create a schema
actually
i can manage my users the authentication
of those users
i can use graphql which i'm going to
present in a second i can create
functions and triggers
and also third party services which is
one what i'm going to use right now
to build the rest api so i go in here
in a third party services and i add a
service
so i could integrate with aws or twilio
or github or other things but what i
want to do here is
http right i want to do a rest api so
i'm going to call it
uh rest api which is very uh
very very very easy to imagine
and uh i'm gonna create a web hook
so this web hook will be the workbook
for the global collection
and it's going to be so running a system
i can log the function arguments if i
send any so why not
and that's basically all i need i also
need to change the http method because
here it's going to be read only api
so it's just a get basically and i'm
going to respond with results
that's also very important of course
because it needs to expect some result
in the body and that's it if i would if
i wanted to secure
this api i could do it with this with
the request validation
but of course i don't really care about
this right now so i'm just going to save
this
and no so the settings are just here so
what i just did and you have now a
function editor where you can actually
set the code that's going to be executed
every time you
call this function you call this webhook
right
so i'm going to do something very very
easy i'm just going to copy paste this
line right here you can delete all that
stuff actually
just keep the function
i'm just going to return this so it's
context contextservice.get
here i retrieve the access to my uh
atlas cluster i don't even need like a
login password because everything is
already integrated
here i'm going to say it was in the
covin 19
database and it's a global collection
and i'm just going to run a find one
just to prove that i can actually return
just the first document that mongodb is
able to find
i hope it's big enough of course yeah it
looks like speaking of
too big actually like that i can save
and now all i need to do is review and
deploy
so here is all the stuff i need i click
deploy
now if i get back it's deployed and now
i go back to settings here and i have
a curl command that i can conveniently
use here is the webhook
url right it is the same one here so i
can just copy paste this
and just copy paste this in a new shell
and as you can see here i have my answer
let's
make this a little bit cleaner
like this
[Music]
and as you can see i have my document
right so
it's already working it's very easy to
do as you can see it takes very
like a few minutes and i am i'm already
returning my documents
um let's uh actually do something a bit
more complex like a real rest api the
one that i actually published in
production
so for this uh i'm just just gonna use
my real code which is a bit more complex
than this but it's really the same thing
it's the same principle
let me just show you how it looks like
so
pretty simple as you can see i'm
retrieving here from the payload
uh the different fields that i need like
the country the state and etc
uh and i'm going to build a query
a projection and a sort which is
actually out coded based on the date
and with this i build my
my query and i just send this query at
the end with the find
i just pass the query the project the
sort
transform this in an array and then i
just set everything
like this in the body and just works
so if i save this again and redeploy
i can now do actually the same thing but
this time
i can just add it big enough
here at the bottom i can just add like
country
equal france for example
and as you can see i have now all the
documents for france
right so it's really how simple at that
okay so now we have a rest api done
let's move on to how to do graphql api
so for this i'm going to go to the
graphql
[Music]
tab here and the first thing i need is a
json schema right because
uh graphql uses schemas right so
click on generate json schema it's
actually gonna lead me to the rules
here in the data access and as you can
see i have all my collections available
i'm going to click on global and
i need to choose a permission template
so here it's a read-only database right
i want to make my data available to
everybody so i'm just going to say
users can read read only all the data
right i'm gonna say configure
in here so i don't really have rules but
i have a schema
so i'm gonna click on schema and i'm
gonna generate a schema
and here as you can see it's gonna
sample
a thousand documents and generate a
schema for me based on
what documents you know it's just uh
it's scanning
in my mongodb collection it takes a few
seconds to just query those documents
and
you know do the analytics to generate
the schema
should be done in a few seconds like
this
and it generates something that looks
like my schema right where i have
confirmed confirm daily country etc etc
the dates etc etc
and i can see that it's missing here it
misses state
uh field right so i can actually fix my
schema if i want to like this and i can
change uh well add state right it's also
a string so i can just
add state because i don't see it
anywhere
and that's it
i'm just going to say save and i'm going
to go to graphql
and now as you can see endpoint has been
generated so that's my graphql endpoint
that i can use
and here i have a graphic url i hope
it's not
too big too large like this looks nice
um and as you can see i have already
accessed to my global
global endpoint and i can just query
documents like this so afghanistan does
not have a state
but if i change this query for example i
think it's
query like this country
france if i do this
i have one of the documents from france
for example
so that's great it's already working
right and if i deploy this
actually i forgot something i need to
make
the authentication available because
this endpoint is of course secured with
authentication right you must be
authenticated to access this so
i need to go to identification and i
couldn't notice it with google
or facebook apis or whatever but i'm
just going to make this anonymous
right so i'm just going to click here
save deploy again
my modification and
and yes so i just need then to retrieve
this
copy app id so that's the application id
of my project that i just created
and i can come in here and here i've
prepared already my
queries so what i need is first retrieve
a token
so i just copy paste here my application
id and i can use this anonymous user
authentication to generate a token
so here as you can see i retrieve an
access token and a refresh token
but i'm just going to use the access
token and in here at the bottom
i hope you can read i hope it's big
enough um
i have prepared a query for my graphql
endpoint
where i'm just going to query for a
french document where the state does not
exist so that's the mainland
for all the documents in march uh i
forgot to change this so
much in here
and just query for the dates and the
confirm daily cases right
so here i copy paste a token here
i need to copy paste my app id
right here
and
and like this i have as you can see all
the documents for
march sorted in order with all the new
number of cases for each day in march in
france right
so yes that's it
so i think i'm done and i'm also at time
so
that's it for me thank you very much